i want to start with a real a sincere
thank you i really do love your work and
i just want to thank you i know people
might not realize that
like no it's really hard making movies i
don't think people realize what really
goes on and i just want to say thank you
for all the effort you put in well thank
you
for thanking me and i
i thank you back so i am curious uh if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before okay what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why um
yeah this you know i always this is sort
of where it started for me i always
wanted to make
an action movie i it was my first love
it made me want to make movies you know
uh i took me a long time to get here
uh obviously there's a lot of great ones
a lot of great action characters so it
took a while to sort of
you know find the right one the right
team
but uh you know this this this this when
i read this i knew this was it you know
not only just because of the russos who
you know if you think you love action
movies they love them more they've spent
the last decade making them and uh you
know just doing an amazing job but also
i thought this character was really
interesting you know he's sort of like a
spy who doesn't want to be a spy he'd
rather be
you know
at home watching netflix like the rest
of us he doesn't want to be in this
movie he doesn't want to have anything
to do with this world he just wants a
normal life
and it's like his his life is anything
but you know so it kind of
he's like a blue collar bond quality to
it that i thought was really um like
just just seemed like a lot of fun uh
this movie has nine action set pieces
and i think you're in all of them um and
so what what day of the shoot were you
like get me the f out of here this is a
little too much
look i i have always wanted to do this
so i couldn't complain you know but it
was sort of there's a moment at the end
of the movie where
um what was the last day of shooting
like suspiciously it was the last day
where i'm running on top of all of these
um train cars and the train the train
cars are falling out from from
underneath me
and i thought this is exactly what this
film has felt like you know it's just
like one insane
action set piece after another just you
know trying to make it out alive
it was uh a trial by fire but it was
also like what made it so
so fun i am a huge fan of when you uh
partner up with derek cena france oh and
i know that uh you guys i have talked
about doing wolfman
is that happening what is it about that
project and getting to work with him
again that is like i want to do this
we're working on it um you know i just
would do anything with derek but like
the idea of doing something like that
just seems really exciting you know it's
it's new for both of us but it's um in
some way i feel like it's
it's kind of the movie we've we've made
already a few times but like in in
but but but in literal form you know
we've always kind of made the
metaphorical version of it and it's sort
of like the opportunity to really
to just make the literal version of what
what we've been hacking away at
so um i i've always loved that character
he's just just an all-time character
just just has always been like
you know on a bucket list for me so i i
i hope we we can do it but you know we
got to get it right
you